and here's what I want to talk about we
have a 1.6 trillion dollar student loan
debt debacle senator Elizabeth Warren
and I have known each other for 27 years
back when she was a harvard law
professor she and I were on the same
side of a bill going through Congress to
reform the bankruptcy laws she and Ted
Kennedy and I which is someone the few
times I've ever been on the same side
Ted Kennedy of anything but we tried to
stop a bankruptcy reform law from going
through it didn't we didn't stop it it
went through Lizabeth and I both
appeared in a documentary 20 years ago I
guess it was called maxed-out that we
both show up in if you find I add a
little bit of hair on top back then it's
that long ago and she is a tremendously
bright woman very very smart and I go
ahead and tell you on the front end of
this discussion I detest all of this
pocahontas stuff and all this stuff
making fun of her DNA testing and her
Cherokee heritage or whatever was that's
a bunch of garbage this lady is an
intellect to be reckoned with
she and I don't agree on hardly anything
except that there's a student loan
problem she's running for president and
I've got great respect for her
personally by the way well I don't have
to agree with everyone I have respect
for and they can be wrong about
something and I can still actually like
them and so I don't have to be all
twisted and trolled and torqued out and
try to get my ratings up I don't have
any trouble with my ratings so I don't
need to you know have a duck fit over
here and make fun of somebody that I
actually respect but she made a comment
this week and it's kind of gone bananas
in all of our chat rooms and in all of
our communities the ramsey communities
everybody's asking about it and in her
run for president she is suggesting that
the student loans be forgiven
and that college be free I don't know
what you think about that what would you
do to fix the student loan problem
because we have a student loan problem I
mean she and I are in agreement about
that we've got people who are
overwhelmed with student loans I talk to
people every day on this show that you
know have made ridiculous mistakes and
but boy they are in a mess as student
loans aren't bankrupt able they don't go
away unless you die so you can go three
hundred thousand dollars in debt getting
a master's degree in left handed
puppetry and be able to get a job making
twenty eight thousand dollars a year and
you're screwed you're in a mess it
happens all the time so we we are not in
disagreement about that so if you want
to talk about this I want to hear from
you what you would do about these
student loans you think they ought to be
forgiven you think College ought to be
free phone number here's triple eight
eight two five five two two five what do
you think about her suggestion now let
me just I'll go ahead and warn you you
can you can make fun of her personally
somewhere else you do not have to attack
someone's character to disagree if it
listen if you can't make an argument
based on the facts and the issues and
you have to degrade someone personally
in order to make your argument then you
don't have an argument you don't know
how to do critical thinking and you
don't know how to debate and so let's
let's talk about these issues you may
disagree with me I may disagree with you
that's fine and you may disagree with
her I disagree with her I'm a capitalist
Pig there's not nothing socialist about
me I would put my receptionist on
straight Commission if I could figure
out a way I think you ought to leave the
cave kill something and drag it home and
then I don't think the government ought
to take it away from you so that's me
and so I'm obviously not going to be for
a socialism thing like free college
because by the way when politician says
something's free
that does not mean free
santa claus does not live in washington
DC somebody's got to pay for that stuff
it's either gonna be more debt that your
children are gonna be government that
deficit spending that your children and
grandchildren are going to pay for or
they're gonna attack somebody somewhere
now she's suggesting a tax on the
ultra-wealthy which has never worked by
the way statistically so she's got a
failed argument there Europe has tried
it in four different countries and
they've stopped it in all of them and
the ultra-wealthy tax doesn't work
there's just not enough ultra wealthy
people to get money from that's the
problem
you've identified the boogeyman with
jealousy and envy and it didn't work so
anyway let's talk to you about what you
would do with the student loans do you
think they ought to be forgiven do you
think college ought to be free
what will you what do you think ought to
be done about the college debacle out
there this is a debacle